as you may know recreational marijuana
recently became legal in the state of
Nevada in fact when Penn & Teller do a
show in Vegas they just kind of flicked
the lights on and off while the audience
stares at a sweet poster of a wizard it
turns out weed is so in demand there
that supplies are running dangerously
low and the governor has issued a
statement of emergency this is a big
deal you guys a state of emergency you
know and you ins have like 30 words for
snow well Nevadans have about 30 words
for heat up some Totino's and watch bad
boys too with the sound off 30 32 words
so what is an announcement that the
government official might make during a
disastrous pot shortage arch warning the
president's tweets are about to make
even less sense all right boys
hogun Penn Jillette ah prostitution is
still illegal gas prices are exorbitant
high so you get neither gas grass nor
ass all right good all right I see the
teller is buzzed in he's got a rectum
damn near killed oh okay great yeah I'll
give you points tonight